right joining us here in the hood is
professor of Technology and education
Andy Van Dam from Brown University and
distinguished scientist Anoop Gupta
Microsoft Research and to talk with us
about some exciting developments in
online education Andy Anoop thanks for
being here appreciate it Chris
we're gonna have some fun here we're
gonna learn some stuff with research in
focus we'll start with you and I
understand you have something pretty
cool to show us today
tell us what office mix is office mix is
a incredibly simple way for people to
create online presentations I basically
build on PowerPoint that a billion
people use to create a you know online
presentation with audio video inking
quizzes in a very simple way it provides
a web-based experience cross-platform
and it gives you analytics on how
students are interacting with what you
created so basically there's a
tremendously simple way to do all of
these things that people have wanted to
do this is exciting stuff so an open
Andy everyone who's gone to college is
experienced you know the traditional
lecture approach to learning and you say
that lectures aren't the best way to
teach which at face value I think is
intuitive to there when you know the old
saying quit lecturing me right we sort
of even associate that name is not the
best way to learn something right so
there are many studies that have shown
the sage on the stage model in some
sense is not a very effective way to
learn you know some work that called
Wyman has done who is a Nobel Prize
winning physicist in the science and
STEM education where he's focused on
shows people get around 30% of the
concepts that the professor intended for
them in the lecture style model and it
comes from a couple of things one is
lectures can quite easily in many cases
become pretty passive experiences for
the students and that's not a way to
learn and the second thing is that you
know as the professor is going if you
miss something there's no way to catch
up before you the next concept comes so
if you don't get lost in someplace
you're maybe lost for quite a while or
and probably many of our
his hair I've experienced not yeah yeah
and Andy I mean you can talk to that I
mean we're kind of living I have a
seven-year-old daughter and a
four-year-old daughter they don't even
know what rewinding the old-fashioned
way is right we're kind of in an
on-demand world I want it now I want to
rewind things I want to pause things
yeah
I've been recording my lectures for much
more than a decade precisely so that
students have a chance after the class
is over to look at the materials at
their own speed and very selectively
they don't need to hear the whole
lecture again they just want to go to
the place where they had some
difficulties and mix gives you a really
good way to do that kind of view so you
guys have proposed that blended learning
is a better way of teaching and so talk
to us exactly about what you mean by
blended learning what blended learning
to me
in a simple way means to use technology
and the humans in appropriate ways so if
there's a broadcast lecture mode that
you're doing you know you could watch
that at home and in fact you can pepper
the online lecture with a bunch of
quizzes interactive exercises
simulations so that you know you're
experiencing you're finding out oh I
wasn't paying attention let me go back
and tried on again and then the way you
use the classroom time in some sense the
people to gather time is to have deeper
discussions to resolve the difficulties
it's often called flipped classrooms
because the notion is you watch the
lecture at home and you come and do the
exercises and the recitation section in
the class and now if blended learning is
arguably a more effective way of
teaching why aren't more schools doing
anything I think they're couple of
challenges why people ant doing it one
is you know there's a long long
tradition off the lecture style means
all of us learnt that way and people are
used to that and changing traditions is
hard it's also not so easy to go to the
online model because so far creating
these online lectures lessons
incrementally updating them and you have
the latest taught has been very
difficult so it is a combination of the
momentum and inertia we have with the
traditional mode with the technological
and the additional work that is needed
that I think makes it hard mm-hmm and
obviously this would be this whole
session be a real downer if we didn't
have some promise for overcoming the
challenges right we're here to prove to
them that it can and should be done
explain how office mix helps teachers
create online lessons so what office
makes a and we should you know get to a
demo pretty simple to this what it does
is it addresses the technological
challenges that I mentioned before it is
a very powerful tool that makes it very
easy to create these online lessons with
interactive elements that you'll want
the students to watch at home it gives
you a very easy way to share with the
students regardless of the kinds of
machines or phones that they're coming
with and finally an important part of
blended learning is that the professor
gets feedback to say what didn't they
get right what did they not get right
and so it automatically provides you
with analytics on how the students
interacted what the misconceptions were
so that yeah you know you can do things
differently in the classroom and we're
gonna jump into the demo but Andy as a
professor you can speak to the fact that
as you sort of indicated sometimes the
biggest thing holding people back has
just changed like I already know how to
do this I already know my lesson plans
and I've got my books why would I want
to learn a whole new computer system
right is it as daunting as it would
appear yeah it is daunting and most of
us don't have the time or the patience
the bandwidth to do it frankly but the
thing I really find impressive about mix
is how fast you can leverage what you
already know how to do which is to make
PowerPoint presentations to add this
enrichment material it was essentially
painless to learn how to use it five
minutes okay you can't ask for more than
that and I'm sure a lot of watching
online are saying prove it prove it if
it's that the demo okay so let's go so
the first thing is you know mixes
publicly available and it's free of
charge that's
so those of you who are listening online
go to mix office comm or you know and
you can find and see and in fact you'll
be seeing what you sing so the first
part is there's a public portal out a I
didn't want to go there so let me just
go back for a second here so you know
there's a bunch of lectures that you'll
see it's a public portal where you can
go and see then in the public portal you
already see a lot of lessons I don't
want to take a couple of them and share
with you their what we can do my machine
is having a little bit of difficulty
actually scrolling so this is not the
one that I wanted to show so you're
gonna have to wait for me on the online
part okay part of the curve and that's
that's part of the curve that's this
basic simple interaction so I'm gonna
take you to this Ohm's law lesson that a
colleague of mine at Microsoft Research
created and this will show you how in
King auto video narration quizzes and
some of the labs can be included free so
let's go there if I can click so here we
are you know so it's just loading you
can see it's full screen beautiful
inking is happening and hopefully you
see the audio thunderclap and
interactions that are taking place you
know you can see out here I'm seeing the
tables of content and I can go and you
know jump around within that so you can
see I just you know went into a slightly
different part of it and you will see
inking taking place you know this is the
nine volt battery you can actually speed
it up in the control that you see out
here to do that you can embed videos
inside it so let me quickly actually
jump into the next video so you know to
keep high schoolers or freshmen excited
so you know this is some fun okay that
is there now next what you seeing is an
interactive lab you know Microsoft
Research has been working on this
technology called touchdevelop which
allows for labs to be there so this is
you know you want to understand the
resistance you want to see you know as I
increase the voltage what happens as I'm
increasing the voltage and you know this
one
hey if I take it beyond 10 milliamps
then it's gonna you know go and crash
and burn and so if I do that boom you
see the sound you can embed quizzes
inside so let me just take you to a
embedded credit quiz inside so you know
here you see a quiz that's gonna pop up
and every interaction that I'm doing
with mix right now is actually getting
recorded in the back end so the
instructor can see how much students
spend time on what portions varied they
have difficulty they can see that I
chose this as an answer and then I
submit it that's incorrect and that you
know I took a second try to get the
answer right so you know all of this
information is available I also did a
quick you know lecture which is the tour
of the mix capabilities and then what
I'm gonna show you is create this live
for you what I just did okay so we gonna
go in here and let's start watching this
office makes its being a little slow on
the K so you can see you you know I was
just recording that the three primary
components you know to the video that is
there you can have authoring within
PowerPoint you know there's a portal so
I'm gonna skip around a little bit so
here we show you know some inking again
and all of the nine different
capabilities that we provide inside of
makes that people can do and then I'm
gonna go and start going quizzes we have
already seen so I'm gonna show you some
additional things that we can do so let
me go into the next one so here we have
if this will go across on the network a
little bit I wanted to show you
basically here we have embedded a Khan
video mm-hm
inside of our mix and you know so all of
the standard Khan Academy stuff works
okay
I have embedded a Khan Academy exercise
inside so I'm just showing you all of
the different kinds of you know
interactable than
can move these dots around and the whole
thing changes I can get a hint these
things as another thing that I put
inside so this is from Colorado the
University of Colorado people have built
some really interesting simulations and
so if I can drag these things there I
can hit go and you can see that you know
pulley if I put two people so again all
of this is being recorded or I can show
you one more thing and then maybe we can
go so this is a Python lab so one of the
most popular languages that is there
today is Python you know that people are
trying to learn and I can go and code
and all of the simulations here you know
are working if I can again my touch is
acting you know so all these jumping
through the exercises can be done smile
so all this interactivity embedded
inside you know lessons that you create
as simple as inserting clip on so let's
go and try and create something like
this yeah we've got less than a minute
you give us the quick tutorial okay so
basically inside PowerPoint mixes an
atom and if you go to the portal again
mixed at office.com you can go and
insert it and within the mix I have a
bunch of things to record audio video
inking add quizzes etc so let's go into
record and this is where you know I'm
gonna make some of the additions so what
I'm gonna do is essentially as I was
doing before okay I'm going to make some
addition so I'm gonna go to record and
here in recording I can say I'm having a
little bit of difficulty with my pen of
course cuz I told you to hurry that's
why you know this pressure round okay so
you know I can encode there and I can
you know I have all of my animations
here coming up and as I'm doing the
animations if this was working you will
actually see my inking working out here
so did all of these things I can do so
right now actually what we will see is
this video and audio is recorded so I
hear I hit the stop button
my whole touches
acting we are you funny so that's what
happens yeah your surface for you they
say you know so you know the reporting
is there and I can preview what is there
you know you can listen to what I just
did and I can move them around so I can
stop the preview hair and then let me
close here so what the other thing I can
do is these videos that are there I can
move them around I can adjust them let
me go to just a blank slide and actually
show you how you add a quiz okay as a
basic thing so I go to this section that
I call quizzes and videos and apps and
as you will see here in the store there
is a wide variety of applications that
we have that you can add and I will just
go to a multiple choice quiz hair and
select that to add and you know let's
take something like what is the nick
name of Seattle and I will not worry
about my spellings right now I'll say
shuffle answers and I can say Emerald
City I can say the Jet City because you
know we have Boeing out there so there's
a variety of cop you know combinations I
can put and then just with a single
upload button that I have out there I
can publish it and you will see the
kinds of explanations you know that for
there and then we can get analytics and
usage so let me stop there yeah no
that's brilliant stuff you shown us it's
really quite as simple as PowerPoint
obviously much more sophisticated I can
see how students will be much more
engaged and because I know we've got
some online questions asking but what
about from the teachers side of it you
said you've got the analytics bills yes
you can see the completion rates what
they're focusing on when they're
stopping yes that stuff right yes that's
fantastic stuff guys thank you Andy and
OOP a better way to teach hard to deny
that where should folks watching go if
they want to try out once again office
mix mix office comm is where they should
go and just to close I think you might
want to look at what are some additional
users how grad students might use it
Andy well for example we all give talks
and usually what we do after the talk is
over is we put our powerpoints or a PDF
on the web
and that's not a very good record of
what you actually did with mix you can
get the entire live session you can see
the annotations come up so it provides
you with a much richer record and you
can use that same style for example all
of us practice our talks I make all my
students go through at least several of
those practice talks well this is a
wonderful tool for again live recording
and then together reviewing and saying
that didn't quite work you need to fix
that slide but not on the basis of your
memory on yes is what it remembers great
style it's good enhancement well we
thank you and the teachers thank you
gentlemen
we appreciate your time today thank you